by land by air
troops have been arriving in large
numbers to reinforce the Dominican
Republic's border since the country
closed it to Haiti
these neighbors who share an island have
always had a tense relationship but now
the Dominican Republic has taken it to
the next level
it's because of this a canal that
Haitian farmers are digging into the
masakri river which the two countries
share
they say they need it to irrigate their
drought hit lands the projects become a
source of local Pride
I'm here as a stone worker the situation
of our country is critical so we have to
put our hands to work to get the canal
done so that our country has food
but the Dominican president isn't happy
he says it diverts a river from
Dominican lands and that he won't open
the Border till they stop digging with
the standoff many Haitian migrants in
Dominican Republic say they're facing
hostilities many are going back home
this is the Queue at the dachabon border
crossing where Dominican officials are
allowing them to cross back into Haiti
Romana Charlie told us that Dominican
police and immigration officers kicked
her and her four children out of her
living space in the middle of the night
three times this week
they grabbed us while we were sleeping
and threw us out with our clothes and
everything if they had done it
professionally no problem but they hit
us and threw around the boys
she's leaving after she says more than
20 years in the Dominican Republic
meanwhile trade between the countries
has also stopped
that's a big problem for Haiti more than
half the country is in danger of
starvation a quarter of its Imports come
from the Dominican Republic it needs the
Border open this won't just hurt Haiti
the Dominican Republic depends on trade
with its neighbor too last year it sent
a billion dollars worth of exports
across the border usually this area
would be bustling with Haitians coming
to buy now these shots are all shut
the Dominican governments promised to
buy up any perishable Goods its
Merchants can't sell
but this standoff doesn't look to end
anytime soon especially since the
Haitian Farmers continue to dig John
Holman Al Jazeera dahabon
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera